[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti come una semplice
fetta di torta
possa aiutarvi a zittire chi sminuisce
oppure a spronarvi verso il successo
no
ma prima di iniziare devo darvi un
compito prendete il cellulare
aprite le note del telefono
e scrivete
quella cosa che avreste voluto fare
nella vita quella passione che riempiva
il vostro cuore quel sogno che avreste
voluto realizzare se
qualcuno non li avesse sminuito
criticato fatto dubitare di voi e delle
vostre capacità
vi lascio qualche istante per scrivere
avete fatto
siete stati sinceri
bene adesso prendete quel sogno
mettetelo in tasca e poi vedremo più
avanti che cosa ne faremo all'interno
del mio toc
oggi vorrei parlarvi di un tipo di
discriminazione invisibile con la quale
purtroppo ognuno di noi ha avuto a che
fare almeno una volta nella vita
l'esperienza di farsi criticare sminuire
da chi non crede in noi in breve vorrei
dirvi come finalmente mettere fine a
tutto questo grazie ad un superpotere la
determinazione
oggi vorrei attraverso il mio top
portarvi a fare un viaggio insieme a me
vorrei farvi assaggiare quella fetta di
torta che mi ha insegnato l'importanza
di darmi un obiettivo
vorrei raccontarvi dell'esperienza più
importante della mia vita che mi ha
spinta ad accettare anche le parti più
difficili nella vita e nel lavoro ed
infine vorrei svelarvi una bizzarra
passione che da ragazzina mi ha spinto a
trasformare le paure in carburante
una domenica
ero a pranzo dai miei nonni con la mia
famiglia mia nonna lina che non era
proprio una massaia ecco non
immaginatevi la classica nonnina che
passa tutto il giorno a cucinare a
stipare il freezer di pasta al forno no
mia nonna era una donna di potere a casa
e al lavoro era lei capo
quindi quella domenica prepara una torta
se la fa fare dalla pasticceria
con una scritta auguri lilly epr
dedicate ai miei genitori perché
festeggiavano il loro anniversario di
matrimonio
poi sotto far giungere la scritta viva
luca dedicata a mio fratello perché
qualche giorno prima aveva vinto una
gara di macchine lui è un pilota
automobilistico io guardo la torta e
dico un po per leader e non ha per ora
iscritto il nome di tutta la famiglia
potevi non so scrivere ciao alice
mia nonna senza neanche pensarci un
istante mi guarda severe e mi dice
quando combinerai qualcosa di buono
faremo una torta anche per te
io
rimango
basita immobile
non è che avesse tutti i torti ecco io
all'epoca non avevo proprio una vita
stabile un fidanzato presentabile alla
comunità un lavoro con la elle maiuscola
avevo la passione per il cinema ma per
una famiglia di imprenditori
la domanda è immediata
esattamente che lavoro vuoi fare
ecco io non mi ricordo se quella
domenica ho assaggiato quella fetta di
torta ma se lo avessi fatto mi sarebbe
andata sicuramente di traverso
da allora per me le torte della nonna
non sono una madre di proust che ricordo
con tenerezza ma mi hanno insegnato a
mettermi degli obiettivi a togliermi
quei paletti mentali ea sostituirli con
scadenze da rispettare gli obiettivi da
raggiungere
e un po come se quel giorno io avessi
detto a me stessa
devo meritarmi la mia fetta di torta ma
non facendo quello che gli altri
vogliono per me
accontentando li mia nonna sperava che
io facessi la commercialista ma
dimostrando a me stessa e agli altri che
posso fare di una passione un lavoro
e allora mi sono chiesta ma alice ma ma
tu che cosa vuoi fare da grande
a tubo e continuare a fare l'assistente
no
no perché per fare un film ci vogliono
mesi lontano da casa e oggi che una
famiglia
lavorare su un progetto che non è mio
non ne vale più la pena
e quindi o di vento regista o cambio
mestiere
[Applauso]
novembre 2019
ero a passeggio con mia figlia più
piccola martina col passeggino
a un certo punto riceve una telefonata è
pronto salve siamo una produzione
cinematografica stiamo cercando dei
registi lei sarebbe disponibile per un
colloquio domani a roma domani a roma
oddio come faccio con la famiglia i
bambini il treno il viaggio per del
treno parto faccio tre colloqui
sbaraglia la concorrenza e scelgono me
finalmente questa è la mia grande
occasione
l'occasione di diventare regista
non devo sprecarla tutto sembra perfetto
ma nemmeno il tempo di godermi la mia
nuova vita da regista che mio marito ha
un terribile incidente sugli sci
io ero al supermercato con martina e
greta mio marito alessandro e lasciare
con gabriele noi abbiamo tre bambini
gabriele greta e martina
mi chiama suo fratello e mi dice guarda
e alessandro ha avuto un incidente ma
non ti preoccupare lo porto in ospedale
solamente per un controllo di routine
io ero al banco frigo e mi sono resa
conto solamente alla cassa che ai miei
figli avevano riempito letteralmente il
carrello di yogurt pago l'importo dei
nonni vado in ospedale
mio marito arriva bianco come un cencio
la dottoressa mi chiama e mi dice
signora non so se riusciamo a metterlo
in sicurezza per trasportarlo d'urgenza
all'ospedale di torino
a chi
sta parlando con me
mio marito
in quel momento tutte le mie certezze
le mie sicurezze crollano mi sento il
pavimento tremare da sotto i piedi
21 elisoccorso ospedale di torino sala
operatoria il chirurgo prima di entrare
mi dice signora se non so come c'e
poi coma
ed infine
il miracolo si è risvegliato con me al
suo fianco sempre visita di verde a
tenergli la mano
e adesso
io che cosa faccio col mio film
continuo
oppure mollo
io oggi sono una mamma una moglie e una
regista io quel giorno non ho mollato e
se questa storia ha insegnato qualcosa a
me che vorrei
raccontare anche a voi e che è
importante amare chi ti sta vicino
ma è anche importante amare quello che
si fa il bello il brutto il difficile è
l'unico modo per amare anche le parti
più difficili della nostra vita e del
nostro lavoro
mondovì
gli avevo detto che da ragazzina avevo
delle idee un po bizzarre
la mia prima battaglia è stata quella di
convincere mio padre a farmi lanciare
col paracadute
avevo 10 anni 10 anni e la passione per
il paracadutismo sportivo
mio nonno mi portava tutte le domenica
al campo volo c'erano i paracadutisti
che si lanciavano da tutte le parti era
uno spettacolo meraviglioso ma volevo
farlo anch'io dovevo però convincere mio
padre e allora insistenza dopo
insistenza pa sono giorni settimane mesi
un anno finché mio padre mi dice ok vuoi
andare andiamo adesso forse pensava di
prendermi alla sprovvista invece salgo
su in camera mia limitarmi a bandana
nera
pronta primo lancio in tandem con
l'istruttore un'emozione pazzesca
ero la più giovane paracadutista
d'italia
da lì però aspettavo i miei sedici anni
perché finalmente avrei potuto lanciarmi
da sola
e così il giorno del mio compleanno
primo lancio
secondo lancio
terzo lancio
emergenza
ecco ho fin da subito capito che i sogni
si sono belli ma più si sogna in alto
più è facile cadere e in questo caso
letteralmente
e quando cadi hai un solo antidoto
sangue freddo e prendere subito una
decisione
aprire il paracadute di emergenza
sembra facile ma
se ci pensi bene
te la fai addosso dalla paura
perché per aprire il paracadute di
emergenza
tu devi abbandonare per sempre il
principale quindi tu devi essere sicuro
al cento per cento che quel paracadute
non ti possa portare a terra in nessun
modo perché una volta che l'hai
sganciato non c'è più e che ne resta
solamente uno nella speranza che
funzioni
ho paura
aveva ragione mio padre
non voglio mai più salire su quell'aereo
ma come un bambino che nonostante quante
volte cade si rialza in piedi per chi
vuole imparare a camminare
io mi sono rimessa la mia tuta da
paracadutista
sono risalita su quell'aereo e mi sono
lanciata non una 25 10 50 60 volte e
questo è per dire anche a voi
utilizzate le critiche e soprattutto le
vostre paure per trasformarle in
carburante invece che riducano in cenere
i vostri sogni e le vostre ambizioni
quando si guarda un obiettivo spesso
sembra impossibile da raggiungere
ti serve decisamente la determinazione
la determinazione per metterci un
obiettivo la determinazione per amare
anche le parti più difficili
la determinazione per trasformare le
paure in carburante e se quella torta la
dividete infette in fettine una fetta
dopo l'altra senza che neanche ve ne
accorgiate vi siete mangiati un'intera
torta e se vi diranno a non sei capace a
quello non è un mestiere
sei una mamma devi pensare i figli tutti
sembra te stesso
sì si può fare con determinazione
e adesso
tirate fuori dalla tasca il vostro sogno
che cosa avete scritto
ditelo ditelo ad alta voce ditelo a voi
stessi di tra gli altri perché questo
siete voi voi al cento per cento quella
è la scritta sulla vostra torta e adesso
alzatevi e lottate per quella dannata
fetta
[Applauso]
[Musica]